bien mes chers collègues alors attendez
parce qu'on commence par
lojari voilà
euh mes chers collègues donc je suis
très heureux aujourd'hui de de pouvoir
accueillir Léo Jarry euh une audition
qui va vous paraître peut-être un peu un
peu
inhabituel mais qui qui pour moi est
importante parce qu'on a eu l'occasion
il y a 2 ou 3 ans maintenant enfin ça
fait 3 4 ans qu'on se connaît il y a de
de ou TR ans on a eu l'occasion avec
huxori notamment de faire un petit
déjeuner avec Léo Jarry parce que je
voulais j'avais invité largement mais il
y avait pas beaucoup de sénateurs qui
étaient présents mais HUG était là et on
a eu été remarquablement impressionné
par le travail qui est fait par cette
ONG et par les informations qui que Léo
était en capacité de de nous fournir
c'était très très utile donc Léo Jarry
Est enquêteur principal à l'ONG conflict
armament resard
euh c'est bon pour tout le monde
monsieur jarier diplômé en droit
international des affaires vous
travaillez au sein de de l'ONG car
depuis 2018 après un passage au
ministère de l'Intérieur et une
expérience dans l'industrie en Afrique
et au Moyen-Orient au sein de car vous
avez d'abord participé aux opérations au
Yémen et en Arabie Saoudite puis en
Libye et au Niger tout en soutenant les
activités de l'organisation en Europe de
l'Est et dans le GO où travaille
actuellement sur l'armement des groupes
djadistes au Sahel ainsi que sur les
filières d'approvisionnement des groupes
armés autour de la mer Rouge créé en
2011 l'ONG conflict arm research produit
des données sur les livraisons d'armes
dans les conflits armés afin d'informer
et de promouvoir une gestion et un
contrôle efficace de ses armes les
équipes d'enquêteurs de car travaillent
ainsi sur le terrain dans les conflits
armés en cours elle documentent les
armes et leur devenir sur leur lieu
d'utilisation qu'ell soit récupéré par
les forces de sécurité de l'État remise
lors de de la cessation d'hostilité
caché ou détenu par les forces insurgées
elle s'efforce de remonter les filières
d'approvisionnement et c'est là que
c'est très intéressant en regroupant les
des données sur des milliers de
transferts d'armes individuels cette ONG
travaille ainsi à la compréhension du
paysage des flux d'armes illicites avec
l'objectif final de contribuer à réduire
la fourniture d'armes aux utilisateurs
non autorisés en particulier aux forces
insurgé et terroristes parmi les récents
rapports thématiques de cette
organisation on peut citer des travaux
sur l'acquisition d'équipements de de
vision nocturne par les talibans sur les
matériels fabriqués par la Corée du Nord
sur les composant de missilees utilisés
par les drones de la de dans la dans le
nord de la Syrie sur la provenance des
armes qui entretiennent le terrorisme
autour du lac Tchad ou encore sur les
armes récupérées par les groupes armés
dans les régions de donetskk de luouansk
à l'est de
l'Ukraine lorsque l'on regarde les
théâtres sur lesquels vous recueillez
des données sur les armes on voit qu'une
grande partie d'entre eux se situent en
Afrique dans trois grands ensembles
l'Afrique de l'Ouest avec le Sahel et le
Golf de Guinée l'Afrique centrale du
Soudan à la RDC et enfin la Corne de
l'Afrique dans ces espaces la
prolifération des armes souvent de petit
calibre a un effet est en effet l'un des
principaux facteurs de transformation
des conflits latant en affrontement
meurtrier cependant nous sommes convenus
que votre intervention d'aujourd'hui
élargirait la la focale en illustrant
cette problématique des conflits vu par
le prisme du trafic d'armes à travers
trois exemples pris dans les trois
régions différentes d'abord le cas d'un
conflit interétatique la guerre en
Ukraine vous évoquerez donc la
provisionnement des forces armées russes
en composant électronique et le
contournement des sanctions et ensuite
le cas d'une guerre de proxy à savoir la
menace posé par anarala en mer Rouge et
le soutien matériel iranien au mouvement
yéménite enfin un sujet qui nous
intéresse du fait des conséquences de
ces conséquences sur pour nos armées en
cours au cours des dernières années la
problématique de l'armement des groupes
djihadistes au
Sael je vous donne la parole pour une
vingtaine de minutes à la suite de quoi
nous aurons comme d'habitude attendez
que je termine l'occasion de de donner
la parole au sénateur qui souhaiteraiit
vous interroger euh voilà moi j'insiste
sur l'importance de cette audition parce
que je trouve qu'on y apprend on a
appris en tout cas j'ai appris à
l'époque euh beaucoup de choses très
intéressantes et je suis très heureux de
vous accueillir à la commission merci
beaucoup et je vous laisse la parole
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs tout d'abord un
très grand merci au nom de conflict
research en tant que simple citoyen pour
l'honneur qui nous a fait euh
j'ai en amont de mon intervention une
question technique m'est-il possible de
projeter euh sur les écrans devant nous
la présentation
prévue
parfait est-ce qu'il serait possible
d'avoir parfa
merci
s les
pH
euh c'est sans doute oui
celui-ci
merci
beaucoup parfait merci beaucoup
en attendant la le le retour d'une
télécommande je me permettrai de de
commencer
l'intervention en présentant quelque peu
l'organisation donc conflict research
comme comme été précisé par Monsieur le
Président a été fondé en 2011 c'est une
ONG qui est soutenue par l'Union
européenne et nous sommes désignés
depuis 2013 par une décision du Conseil
de l'Union européenne comme maître
d'œuvre de la stratégie de l'Union pour
la lutte contre le trafic d'armes nous
travaillons en plus de cela avec un
certain nombre de pays et de partenaires
institutionnels d'organisations
multilatérales parmi lesquelles Europol
Interpol unafor le Department of State
américains et tant d'autres y compris
plusieurs branches des nations- Unies
l'objectif de car c'est d'être capable
de collecter sur le terrain de la donnée
relative aux armes et de la donnée
tangible c'est-à-dire que nous adoptons
une méthodologie quasi scientifique nous
ne rapportons et nous n'étudions que ce
que nous profilons physiquement et donc
nous nous déployons sur les zones de
tension en accord avec les autorités
locales pour avoir accès à cette donnée
armement ah formidable merci
beaucoup le trafic d'armes que ce soit
dans la littérature française ou dans la
culture populaire a toujours fait
l'objet d'un certain fantasme que ce
soit les tribulations d'Henri de
montfred ou d'Arthur rimbaau en
abicini il il est il est il est en
revanche aussi extrêmement utile
lorsqu'on le regarde sous un prisme le
prisme des données
ah
donc je poursuis ce traxfic d'arme est
particulièrement utile pour avoir un
prisme assez différent sur les
dynamiques des conflits et j'espère
aujourd'hui pouvoir vous donner une
approche une approche assez assez
novatrice assez propre àart pour
regarder trois conflits
différents et étudier d'abord sur le
conflit ukrainien la question de
l'efficacité des
sanctions de la vulnérabilité des
chaînes d'approvisionnement des
forcesâes Russes parler était capable
ensuite de caractériser la chaîne
d'approvisionnement de Ansar
c'est-à-dire des his au Yémen et en mer
Rouge qui aujourd'hui sont une menace
grandissante pour la liberté la liberté
du commerce et
enfin avoir un un autre point de vue sur
l'arsenal des groupes djihadistes au
Sahel qui eux opèent sans avoir un
soutien étatique
extérieur et dès que j'aurai un retour
de
télécommande je commencerai cette
intervention
pardon sur le
bout
la 7
compagnie
formidable formidable merci
beaucoup
formidable S entir trop longuement sur
ce la nature de de de notre organisation
voici un peu la cartographie de nos
opérations les zones sur lequelles sur
lesquel dans lesquel nous intervenons
donc on a une couverture assez large en
chiffre rapidement car a documenté
plusieurs de centaines de milliers
d'armes plusieurs centaines de milliers
de munitions a été a été ou est
opérationnel dans plus de 25 pays et
concrètement ce que représente le
travail de car sur le terrain etust par
la par par la photo c-dessous euh
c'est-à-dire on passons une plus CLA de
notre temps assis ou allongé avec des
saisis à trier à inventorier et des
matériels à
profiler de ce profilage nous tirons des
éléments extrêmement tangibles numérro
de série euh type de matériel logo de
fabricant et cetera et nous essayons de
retracer l'origine de ce
matériel nous disposons d'une équipe en
Ukraine depuis 2016 environ
et nous avons publié un certain nombre
de rapports une douzaine sur l'évolution
des systèmes d'armement qui étaient
saisis par les forces ucrainienne et qui
permettent d'appréhender les dynamiques
et les chaînes d'approvisionnement des
forces armées
russes une chose qui nous paraissait
extrêmement importante d'aborder
aujourd'hui c'est la question de
l'efficacité des sanctions c'est quelque
chose qui fait l'objet d'énormément de
débats et car a un point de vue
extrêmement bien sûrou centré sur sur
sur celui des composants électroniques
mais nous pensons qu'il illustre bien la
dynamique plus large ce que car observe
en Ukraine depuis depuis le début de son
intervention c'est que les Russes et les
forces armées russes ont mis en place
une stratégie de stockage de composants
électroniques
entre 2014 et 2022 cette constitution de
stock a permis à l'armée russe et l'État
russe de se prémunir temporairement de
l'effet des sanctions
de 2022 de l'intervention russe jusqu'à
mi-2023 on observait une consommation
des stocks préexistants comment est-ce
qu'on observait cela dans tous les sy de
rus des systèmes d'armes russes que l'on
documentait en Ukraine que ce soit des
drones des missiles des systèmes de
télécommunication et cetera lorsque nous
les disséquions nous regardions les
numéros de série les chaînes
d'approvisionnement de ces composants
électroniques ceci avait été acquis
avant l'intervention russe depuis
mi-2023
les composants que nous documentons dans
les systèmes d'armes russes ont été
fabriqués après 2022 après l'invasion
russe et donc après la mise en œuvre des
sanctions vous avez là sur la photo le
l'exemple d'un d'une munition reuse
landet russe dans laquelle en mars
dernier mars 2023 nous avons documenté
pour la première fois des composants
fabriqué après
2022 comme je disa cette stratégie de
stockage elle a permis aux forces armées
russes de de une certaine leur donner
une certaine résilience temporaire face
à ces sanctions puisque elle pouvait
utiliser librement ces stocks là sans
avoir à
s'approvisionner en s'approvisionner
mais aussi elle a permis à la Russie de
défendre un narratif très
utile quant à la question de
l'inefficacité des sanctions et vous
aviez que ce soit en Russie pour les
citoyens russes ou à l'extérieur tout un
narratif sur la question de cette
inefficacité des sanctions de dire mais
si les russes continuent à pouvoir
produire de l'armement c'est que ce que
nous imposons à nos entreprises et à nos
citoyens n'est pas efficace et il faut
donc penser à autre chose ce que l'on
voit sur la photo la photo
d'illustration que vous voyez là ce sont
les restes de composants électroniques
d'un missile de croisière russe kh59 et
tous les composants que vous voyez là ce
sont des composants qui avaient été
acquis avant l'invasion russe
voici donc ce que nous commençons à
observer aujourd'hui c'est que les
forces armées russes deviennent
extrêmement dépendantes de
l'approvisionnement de d'un
approvisionnement présent de même ce que
l'on note beaucoup chez conflict
research c'est que ces composants en
très grande majorité non russes très
souvent occidentaux nous y reviendront
se retrouve non pas dans un seul système
mais dans différents systèmes
d'armes vous avez par exemple ici un
circuit intégré que l'on retrouve dans
quatre types de missiles différents dans
quatre systèmes de navigation de
missiles différents alors je ne vous
listerai pas les les systèmes de
missiles sauf si ça vous intéresse mais
ce qui est intéressant c'est que une
perturbation de ces chaînes
d'approvisionnement
entraînerait des conséquences assez
importantes sur la capacité de
production russe mais aussi sur les
capacités de maintien en condition
opérationnell et donc en perturbant une
chaîne d'approvision à partir d'un
élément comme celui-ci est en temps
général disséminé dans plusieurs
systèmes d'armement vous avez un impact
aux effets
démultipliés enfin je tiens à souligner
que il y a et il existe encore
aujourd'hui un quasi monopole
technologique occidentale et puis de de
nos alliés c'est par exemple le Japon
Taiwan la Corée du Nord sur les les
puces et les circuits intégrés avancés
Corée du Sud
excusez-moi
effectivement je je m'avance de quelques
décennies et donc et cette ce quasi
monopole technologique n'est pas en
passe d'être dépassé aujourd'hui par le
développement de technologies alternativ
dans d'autres pays et donc ces systèmes
et ces productions occidentales sont
encore aujourd'hui une source absolument
nécessaire pour les forces armées
russes quelques
chiffres presque 100 % des composants
électroniques documentés dans les drones
russes sont fabriqués en Occident
50 % des composants électroniques
documentés dans les missiles russes dans
les munitions guidées sont aussi
fabriqués en Occident ce qui est très
intéressant parce que ces technologies
de de balistique russes notamment donc
pour les missiles ont été développé il y
a ex très longtemps les Russes étaient
parmi les premiers à développer ce type
de technologie mais aujourd'hui avec
l'avancement des capacités ils ont
besoin de s'appuyer sur des productions
extérieur ils ont les Russes ont une
capacité de rétroingénierie et de
production domestique extrêmement limité
un exemple c'est sur la photo que vous
voyez ici dessous vous avez là un
système qu'on appelle avec un acronyme
un peu barbare je m'en excuse
umpk qui permet de mieux guider
certaines bombes russes et ce système-ci
s'il est développé domestiquement
embarque uniquement des composants
électroniques occidentaux d'autres
systèmes de navigation russe très
important qui équipe d'autres drones
notamment Cometa même s'ils sont
produits localement embarque uniquement
des circuits intégrés des puces
occidentales ce que vous ne voyez pas
bien sur la photo mais je souhaite aussi
souligner c'est que les marquages sur
ces puces là ont été
effacé bien sûr cela rendes
investigations beaucoup plus difficiles
pas seulement les nôtres celles aussi de
service étatique mais cela aussi
soulligne la volonté par de par les
Russes de limiter la vulnérabilité
qu'offre la TR trçabilité de ces
composants donc eux-mêmes sont
extrêmement conscients de la
vulnérabilité de cette chaîne
d'approvisionnement pour ce qui est de
la question du des circuits de
contournement des sanctions ce que l'on
observe c'est que les entreprises russes
qui sont les utilisateurs finaux n'ont
pas beaucoup changé en revanche on note
depuis l'instauration des sanctions
l'apparition d'entreprises
intermédiaires beaucoup sont situés en
Chine à Hong Kong et en Europe de
l'Est je tiens à souligner que il existe
peut-être un biais statistique parce
qu'il est beaucoup plus facile pour nous
d'avoir et de récupérer de la donnée sur
les entreprises en Chine que dans
d'autres places fortes du commerce
international mais en tout cas on a
identifié bien plus d'une centaine
d'entités privées qui servent
d'intermédiaire qui font office
d'intermédiaire entre les entreprises
fabricantes occidental et les
entreprises russes qui ensuite délivrent
ces matériels aux forces armées ou ou
aux entreprises de fabrication de
d'armement je note tout de même que les
entreprises fabricantes occidentales
sont généralement victimes il y a très
peu de cas où les entreprises de
fabrication occidentale étaient au
courant où ont agi avec négligence euh
dans dans dans leurs affaires et nous
n'appelons pas du tout un régime
beaucoup plus dur
euh dans dans les dans les dans dans
comment dire un régime qui serait qui
imposerait beaucoup plus de de de
rigueur euh aux aux industriels ce que
nous souhaitons surtout et ce que nous
pensons être extrêmement utile c'est un
travail conjoint avec l'industrie
l'industrie est vraiment la clé pour
identifier ces différentes entités
intermédiaires sur l'efficacité des
sanctions donc ce que l'on voit c'est
que l'efficacité des sanctions s'accroit
dans le temps en réalité c'est parce que
les les les stocks de de de composants
électroniques préexistants se sont
épuisés ou s'épuisent qu'aujourd'hui les
sanctions prennent tout leur
sens cela souligne aussi bien sûr
l'importance d'une traque continue des
entités qui permettent et des entités
intermédire qui permettent cet
approvisionnement des forces russes
c'est un petit peu un un jeu du chat et
de la souris puisque ces entités une
fois qu'elles ont été décelé sont
abandonnés d'autres sont recréés mais
cela si vous si si on opère cette traque
avec rigueur cela met une pression
énorme sur les circuits
d'approvisionnement des forces armées
russes enfin je note pour illustrer ce
propos-l que l'on observe des cycles de
vie parfois très courts pour l'armement
russe l'exemple que vous avez là c'est
une photo des restes d'un missile
kh101 donc qui a été documenté par car
le 25 novembre
2022 ce qui est intéressant c'est que à
la lecture du numéro de série on est
capable de déterminer la date de
production au 3e trimestre 2022 ce qui
veut dire que ce missile a été produit
très peu de temps avant son utilisation
et c'est quelque chose que l'on observe
avec une grande grande partie des
systèmes d'armement russes des systèmes
avancés qui embarent des circuits
électroniques ce qui indique que les
forces amé russes fonctionnent avec
assez peu de
stock pardon il y a bien sûr la question
du soutien matériel extérieur euh aux
forces armées russes la trouvaille la
plus récente de
car se situe sur cette photo ce sont les
restes d'un missile kn23 ou kn24
nord-coréen qui a été documenté il y a
quelques jours en Ukraine par nos
équipes ce qui est intéressant c'est
que il est peu probable que la Russie
soit allée de guêter de cœur euh
demander de l'aide à à Pyongyang il est
aussi intéressant de voir que ponggang a
accédé aux requettes de Moscou et il
leur a fourni un matériel qui fait
partie de l'arsenal de pointe du régime
nord-coréen l'autre soutien matériel
extérieur qui fait beaucoup de bruit
c'est le soutien matériel iranien
celui-ci se compose surtout de drones
des drones chaed un peu munition reuse
ces fameux drones kamikaz 131 136 238
les modèles et les drones moager 6 qui
sont des drones de combat ce que vous
voyez sur la photo ce sont les reste
d'un drone shaet 136 documenté par car
en Ukraine ce type de drone est utilisé
aujourd'hui en mer Rouge par
les il a été utilisé aussi au
Moyen-Orient et documenté par car sur
ces trois théâtres
ce qui est très intéressant quand on
dissèque le matériel iranien en Ukraine
c'est que la plupart des composants que
l'on documente dans ces drones ont été
fabriqués après 2020 avec un pic de
production en 2020- 2021 qu'est-ce que
cela veut dire c'est que il semblerait
que l'Iran n'ait pas été préparé à
soutenir en amont matériellement la
Russie l'Iran a des C l'Iran lorsqu'elle
produit ses drones ces drones-ci ont des
cy de vie très court la photographie que
vous voyez là en est une preuve c'est un
autocollant que l'on a retrouvé sur une
batterie de drone kamikaz shaed 136 en
Ukraine sur cette batterie vous voyez au
7e mois de l'année 2023 le la date
limite de de longévité de la batterie et
ça indique que cette batterie et ce ce
ce drone ched ont probablement été
assemblé et sinon fabriqué au début de
l'année 2023 et nous l'avons documenté
en mai 2023 en Ukraine et donc il y a un
circuit extrêmement court un cycle de
vie extrêmement court de ces matériels
ce qui indiquerait qu'il y a aussi là
aussi peu de stock
disponible ce qui aussi explique
pourquoi les Russes en partie explique
pourquoi les Russes ont voulu développer
leur propre drone chahet si j'ose dire à
travers un drone que l'on appelle le
Guan 2 le Guan 2 et le Guan et le Guan 2
je rentrerai pas trop dans le détail
technique mais cela donne une idée un
petit peu de défi euh que que que que
qui qui se qui s'impose aux forces
armées russes sur la question du
management des
stocks je note aussi que dans ce dans
ces drones iraniens on retrouve une
grande majorité de composants
occidentaux là encore du fait du
monopole technologique occidental en
revanche les Iraniens semblent avoir
développé une certaine capacité de
rétroingénierie sur des pièces comme les
moteurs les gyroscopes et
cetera ce qui est très intéressant pour
nous c'est que nous opérons en règle
générale par corrélation nous regardons
et nous comparons ce que nous trouvons
sur différentes théâtre et bien sûr un
des sujets les plus importants du moment
c'est celui de la menace posée par le
groupe ansaralla communément appelé hi
en mer
Rouge car a longuement publié sur les
dynamiques de la région et ce que nous
observons et ce que nous essayons de
caractériser
ce sont les circuits d'
d'approvisionnement par l'Iran mais
aussi autonome par les housi en
matériel car a énormément documenté
d'armes de munitions de composants
d'engin explosif improvisés et de drone
en provenance d'Iran au Yémen ou saisi
au
Yémen ce qu'il faut noter tout de même
c'est que ansaralla et les hi s'appuient
sur un arsenal préexistant l'arsenal
yeménite préexistant et des capacités de
production domestique on sait par
exemple et on a beaucoup documenté des
mines et des engins explosifs improvisés
produits en quantité industrielles parce
que les Houis pouvaient s'appuyer sur
des capacités euh de de de de
manufacture
domestique enfin et c'est un petit peu
euh l'essence de cette guerre par
procuration il y a une appropriation
partielle de l'assemblage euh et de
l'approvisionnement par les housis qui
ne sont pas soutenu à bout de bras sur
toutes les composantes euh de leur
système d'armement par l'Iran ce que
l'on observe souvent c'est que un
système d'armement avancé un drone va
tout d'abord être fourni en kit au housi
et puis petit à petit uniquement
certaines pièces cruciales vont être
envoyées depuis l'Iran le reste va être
directement acquis par les housi de
manière autonome en règle générale c'est
l'exemple de cette photo les fuselages
sont toujours sont toujours envoyés
depuis l'Iran ou fourni par l'Iran là où
certaines pièces comme les moteurs de
drone notamment sont acquis directement
de manière autonome par
les en terme de circuit logistique on a
différents cas car a beaucoup documenté
de transfert en mer puisqu'on parle de
guerre par procuration il y a une
volonté de dénis plausible de la part de
la part des des forces iraniennes et
donc on a souvent observé notamment pour
ce qui était de transfert de composants
d'engin explosif improvisiier de
précurseurs comme par exemple des
fertilisants ou d'armes et des munitions
des transferts en mer c'està-dire dire
que des petits boutres domiciliés au
Yémen ou en Somalie avec des équipages
de la même nationalité se
rendaient plus enfin dans les environs
dans les eau dans les eaux iraniennes
pour se voir transférer un certain
nombre de matériel avant de même les les
transporter jusqu'au Yémen
ensuite nous avons le cas du trafic
terrestre parfois nous n'avons pas de
saisie en
mer possiblement parce que la logistique
maritime est directement faite par des
entités souveraines donc cela empêche en
règle générale les les les saisies en
mer ce que l'on observe sur le trafic
terrestre c'est une dissimulation de
matériel donc dans certains conv voie
donc ça peut être des armes des
notamment des armes antitank ça peut
être des drones et cetera mais aussi
dans les notamment dans les
approvisionnements autonomes une
utilisation de réseau d'affaires pour se
procurer des composants notamment
d'engins explosif improvisés ou encore
des pièces de drone un cas emblématique
de ces derniers
mois est relatif à des moteurs de drone
et ce qui s'est passé c'est que les his
se sont appuyés sur le commerce
international pour tout simplement
s'improviser en moteur de drone jusqu'à
jusqu'à un port de la région et ensuite
pour ensuite pour dissimuler cette
première cargaison dans une seconde qui
a été transporté par voie terrestre
jusqu'au
Yémen je tiens à dire que ce qui permet
cette logistique là c'est aussi
le fait qu'il y ait des réseaux de
trafic si j'ose dire ou presque une une
une contrebande coutumière dans la
région et donc vous avez les boutres qui
opèrent entre l'Afrique de l'Est et puis
le golf et puis jusqu'à l'Asie du du
Sud-Est qui sont une image extrêmement
extrêmement courante et en général les
autorités locales s'accommodent assez
bien de de ces activités là qui
considèent comme faisant partie du
paysage vous avez aussi la question
question de la contrebande
traditionnelle si j'ose dire terrestre
notamment dans les régions frontalières
d'Oman les régions yménite frontalière
Doman dans le gouvern gouvernera pardon
du had la
Maut un des exemples que on peut vous
donner qui est illustré par la photo
c'est le navire le boutre que vous voyez
là le jan one qui a été sur lequel a été
saisi en
2013 tout un matériel des composants
d'engin explosif improvisé radiocommande
en provenance d'Iran des et d'autres
d'autres d'autres systèmes d'armes et
car a documenté des systèmes similaires
à partir de 2017 au Yémen et donc je dis
ça pourquoi pour dire que ce sont des
circuits assez
longs et ce sont il y a une volonté
réelle de la part à la fois des his et
des Iraniens de diversifier leur circuit
d'approvisionnement leur circuit
logistique en terme de prospective sur
le Yémen euh car opère beaucoup et
travaille beaucoup avec à la fois les
forces navales déployées dans la région
y compris européenne euh et puis avec
les les les les les comment dire les
entreprises qui opèrent dans le maritime
donc ça peut être les entreprises de
shipping ou d'autres celle-ci nous
approche pour nous demander un petit peu
de faire une évaluation de la menace et
de savoir à quoi faut-il s'attendre à
l'avenir une des choses que l'on que
l'on que que que l'on observe ou une des
choses que l'on essaye de déterminer
c'est par corrélation avec ce que l'on
observe sur d'autres théâtres comment la
menace peut-elle évoluer en mer Rouge
sans aller trop dans le détail on a
observé beaucoup de corrélations euh un
exemple que l'on souhaite donner c'est
la photo que vous voyez en bas à droite
c'est une ogive ce que vous si j'ose
dire plantez sur une sur sur une
munition et euh qui est modulable dans
ce qui est du chaed c'est-à-dire que
vous pouvez avoir différentes ogifes qui
vont avoir différents effets certains
vont avoir un effet
de souffle beaucoup plus puissant
d'autres vont être beaucoup plus
pénétrants et cetera et donc cette
modularité que l'on n'a pas encore
observé au Yémen on l'a observé en
Ukraine on a notamment observé en
Ukraine que ces drones chaed pour être
guidés embarqué avec eux des téléphones
satellite ce qui n'a pas encore été
observé au yemmen mais qui permet déjà
de préparer une réponse à cette menace
avec les opérateurs les les opérateurs
intéressés enfin certains groupes
terroristes contrairement aui àarala ne
bénéficient pas d'un soutien matériel
extérieur c'est notamment le cas de
l'armement des groupes djihadistes au
Sahel car a aussi beaucoup publié sur ce
sujet et nous publions à la fin du mois
trois rapports sur spécifique
spécifiquement sur l'armement des
groupes djihadistes au Sahel Niger Mali
Burkina
Faso voilà une cartographie des saisies
li au djihadisme que nous avons
documenté dans la région vous avez en
bleu foncé notamment à droite dans le
sud-est du Niger les saisies liées à
l'état islamique en Afrique de l'Ouest
et précédemment à
bokoaram vous avez en gvert si j'ose
dire les saisis lié à l'état islamique
au Grand Sahara vous avez en jaune en
orange excusez-moi les saisis lié au
gennim donc Al-Qaïda et Hongrie des
saisis qui ont été déterminés comme
djihadistes mais pour lesquels nous
n'avons pas pu déterminer le groupe
d'appartenance qui se divise entre ces
trois grandes
branches en règle générale ce que nous
observons sur les sources
d'approvisionnement en armes et en
munition pour les groupes djihadistes au
Sahel c'est la chose suivante c'est que
la très grande partie de leur arsenal
provient du détournement de stocks
nationaux ceuxci les groupes les groupes
djihadistes pillent les stocks nationaux
ils attaquent des bases des postes de
sécurité et cetera ça répond à un double
objectif bien sûr sapprovisionner
matériel mais aussi bien sûr faire
reculer l'état contrôler du
territoire les groupes djihadistes
s'approvisionnent aussi beaucoup sur un
armement qui est hérité des conflits
régionaux intérieurs il y a une certaine
porosité entre les différents conflits
donc vous pouveiez avoir par exemple les
rébellions en Côte d'Ivoire ou les
insurrections ont donné lieu à de grand
d'importants circuits euh de de ou
d'importants mouvements d'armes
licites enfin et on est là sur une
proportion somme toutes mineure et
plutôt anecdotique il y a effectivement
un armement détourné des stocks de la
jamaheria libyenne pourquoi je note
anecdotique parce que en règle générale
on entend souvent que ces stocksl
auraient finalement euh été l'essentiel
aurait constitué l'essentiel de
l'armement des groupes djihadistes au
Sahel c'est faux et c'est de moins en
moins vrai et enfin et là nous sommes
vraiment dans l'anecdotique et dans
quelques cas à de très r dans de très R
res occasions les groupes djihadistes
vont s'approvisionner sur les marchés
noirs c'est extrêmement rare ils ne
souhaitent pas dépenser d'argent pour
cela et en règle générale lorsqu'on a
documenté des cas similaires c'était
plutôt des individus qui étaient
djihadistes en soirée bandit de grand
chemin en
matinée
évidemment une chose qui est importante
de souligner c'est l'absence formel
d'éléments accréditant la thèse d'un
soutien étatique extérieur les données
que
car récupère dans ces régions elle les
récupère au profit avant tout des états
de ces régions et donc en dépit si j'ose
dire des déclarations qui ont pu être
faites le travail qui est fait avec ces
états indique qu'il n'y a aucun soutien
d'un état extérieur au groupe
djihadistes dans la région et car
publiera ses rapports avec le
partenariat de chacun de ses
états voilà pour la règle si j'ose dire
on observe une certaine soumadision les
les groupes terroristes s'appuient avant
tout sur le pillage de stocks nationaux
les organisations criminelles tierces
s'approvisionnent principalement sur les
marchés noirs ceux qui vont vivre si
j'ose dire les marchés noirs ce sont les
groupes criminels mais aussi les
particuliers et en même temps
aujourd'hui avec le développement des
groupes de vigilance des groupes
d'autodéfense et cetera ces derniers je
pourrais revenir si vous avez des
questions là-dessus sur ce qui constitue
ces ces ces réseaux d'approvisionnement
de manière plus précise mais je veux pas
je veux pas vous inonder d'informations
sur ce sujet
là tout de
suite
hop pardon voilà pour ce qui est des
armes en provenance de Libye on observe
aussi une évolution très nette de 2011 à
2021 la majeure partie des stocks qui
descendaient de Libye pour inonder le
Sahel et l'Afrique de l'Ouest étaient is
des stocks de la jamaahiria libyenne
stock de Kaddafi depuis 2021 on a une
hausse de de de de de la part des
munitions et et des armes fabriqué après
2011 dans les saisis c'est-à-dire que
dans les saisis qui proviennent de Libye
et qui sont opéré au Niger au Mali au
Burkina Faso au Nigeria vous avez de
plus en plus d'armes qui ont été
introduites en Libye en violation des
sanctions et après les soulèvements
libiens de 2011 ce qui veut dire que la
menace aujourd'hui qui est posée par C
par par par les circuits illicites en
provenance de Libye est une menace si
j'ose dire renouvelée c'est quelque
chose qui est la cons conséquence de
l'intervention en Libye d'acteurs
tierces d'État étranger qui ont souhaité
soutenir certains acteurs libiens j'ai
plusieurs cas d'études d'études de cas
excusez-moi sur ces sujets-là je ne veux
pas vous les donner tout de suite ou si
vous avez des questions spécifiquement
sur ces sur ces dynamiqu là on pourra y
revenir je vous remercie pour votre
attention et je souhaitais euh terminer
mon
intervention en soulignant que les les
armes sont en général fascinantes c'est
vrai
elles servent quand même lorsqu'elles
sont prises pour ce qu'elles sont
c'est-à-dire des indicateurs elles
servent quand même à lire les conflits
de manière extrêmement précise et à
lutter contre la mésinformation ou la
désinformation j'espère que je n'ai pas
été trop technique ou trop long
évidemment c'est un peu notre métier
d'être passionné par ce sujet-là et il y
a un poète syrien qui dans un de ces
poèmes les plus célèbres qui expliquait
la vie autour d'un d'un d'un poste d'un
poste de contrôle à Damas terminer sa
poésie avec ses versis mon Dieu pourquoi
faut-il que ces instruments de mort
soient aussi beaux je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Jarry
euh on a un certain nombre de demande de
questions euh peut-être après on je
peut-être que les questions seront dans
les mienes mes questions seront dans les
votres donc je vais pas les poser euh je
commence par Michel
Grum merci monsieur le Président merci
beauoup beaucoup pour votre rapport on
ne peut que constater que malgré les
sanctions françaises européennes
américaines et l'embargo international
les entités rus sont acquis des
composants matériels Nord Coréens
iraniens liby mais également dans l'un
des rapports de votre on ce sont des
composants britanniques tchques français
allemands espagnols et américains pour
des composants utilisé dans les drones
la question sur la livraison d'ailleurs
de ces des composants français à la
Russie a été posé par mon collègue
Robert xovi du 11 octobre 2023 ministre
de l'armée et qui est resté sans réponse
encore aujourd'hui il est clair que
l'utilisation de matériel acquis avant
la guerre de l'Ukraine doit nous
interpeller sur le contrôle du commerce
d'armes d'ailleurs mon groupe a déposé
en 2022 une proposition de loi visant à
renforcer le contrôle sur le commerce
des armes avec notamment la création
d'une délégation parlementaire en charge
de contrôler l'exportation des armes
nous proposons également la suppression
des licences d'exportation globale qui
constitue selon nous une source
d'opacité selon vous que
préconisiez-vous pour éviter au maximum
la prolifération des armes
conventionnelles et autres bienens à
double usage
merci je fais trois séries de questions
la la la parole pardon est à Hux
Sori merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur vous avez décrit j'ai une
question qui concerne les armes légères
vous avez décrit le Che ement d'un
certain nombre d'armes et leur lieux de
production on voit qu'il y a une
centralisation finalement de la
production d'armes or on voit aussi que
depuis un certain temps des imprimantes
3D sont capables de fabriquer des armes
c'està-dire que on pourrait imaginer et
c'est le la question que je vous pose
que demain il y a décentralisation de la
production de ces armes légères je
voulais savoir si pour vous c'était une
piste qui était envisageable et quelles
en seraient les les conséquences je vous
remercie merci HUG et enfin Roger
carouci
oui monsieur le Président moi je
voudrais d'abord féliciter car de faire
autant de constats mais est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas un peu dans l'amertume en
permanence parce
que vous nous dites très très très
justement que l'Iran est à l'origine de
presque tous les trafics vers les
mouvements terroristes vers la Russie
vers
d'autres vous travaillez entre
guillemets pour avec l'Union européenne
je vois pas beaucoup de rétorsion de
l'Union européenne je vois pas beaucoup
de décisions européenne pour sanctionner
en réalité l'Iran sur ces trafic d'armes
on a vu il y a quelques jours Joseph
Borel faire un accueil chaleureux au
ministre iranien des Affaires étrangères
et on a vu hier notre ministre des
Affaires étrangères faire beaucoup de
compliments à son homologue iranien
parce que que vous avez pas le sentiment
que d'un côté on fait des constats
terribles sur il livre des armes partout
ils sont des facteurs de destruction
mais qu'en réalité B comment dire la
politique étrangère est en ce qu'elle
est on fait des constats mais on en tire
aucune conclusion c'està-dire que je
vois pas beaucoup de sanctions je vois
pas beaucoup d'efficacité des
sanctions est-ce que tout ça est pas un
peu irréaliste en vrai
merci Roger pour cet
optimisme la parole est à vous monsieur
merci monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice sur la
question des
préconisations ce que je souhaiterais
préciser en amont c'est
que une chose qu'il est importante de de
noter lorsque l'on observe lorsqu'on
étudie cette question des circuits
d'approvisionnement c'est celle de la
date de fabrication une bonne partie des
composants y compris sur les lesquels
notre organisation a travaillé sont des
composants qui avaient été fabriqués
avant 2022 et donc avant l'instauration
des sanctions donc il y a un effet de
volume où beaucoup de ces de de de ces
composants là sont arrivés en Russie si
j'ose dire avant que la Russie ne se
rende coupable de de de l'invasion de
l'Ukraine et donc si à partir de là on
constate une inefficacité du régime de
sanction
finalement on fait un peu le jeu de
cette de comment dire de du narratif qui
vise à à discréditer les régimes de
sanction parce queils auraient fait des
stocks préexistants hélas la guerre
demande beaucoup de ressources et donc
ces stocks s'épuisent petit à petit et
donc ce que l'on voit aujourd'hui c'est
que comme j'ai essayé de le démontrer
nous avons des circuits de plus en plus
récents et puis surtout des cycles de
vie dans de système d'armement de plus
en plus court ce qui veut dire que les
sanctions même si elles peuvent être
imparfaites
fonctionnent c'est un effort qui doit
être sans cesse réitéré en encore une
fois à partir du moment où vous
débusquez si j'ose dire un intermédiaire
un autre sera peut-être créé derrière
mais il faut vous dire que du point de
vue si j'ose dire de russe il y a un peu
ce même sentiment de de de d'effort vain
cette idée que bah finalement on va
réouvrir à chaque fois des entreprises
mais elles seront peut-être à un moment
identifié fermées cela coûte extrêmement
cher ça prend beaucoup de temps et donc
il y a ce phénomène là je je je je vous
souhaiterais aussi rappeler à ce titre
que
il y a eu il y a quelques mois beaucoup
de rumeurs au sujet d'une prétendue d'un
prétendu pillage d'appareil
électroménagé par la Russie pour
s'approvisionner en circuit électrique
c'est tout à fait faux ça n'a jamais été
le cas nous n'avons jamais observer ça
pour deux
raisons tout d'abord pour les sur les
sur les capacités techniques
c'est-à-dire que vous ne trouverez pas
dans votre grip pas un système de
navigation j'en suis désolé le marketing
est parfois mensonger
et puis il y a au-delà de ça une affaire
de coût ces composants pris
individuellement coûtent quand même
assez peu cher si vous devait acheter
une machine à laver pour récupérer un
circuit qui en plus ne sera pas un
circuit intégré extrêmement avancé une
machine à lav qui coû qui coûterait
disons 500 dollars euh vous allez vite
vous retrouver à sec si j'ose dire donc
il y a un peu ce phénomène où
effectivement on peut dire que les
sanctions ne fonctionnent pas parce
qu'elles n'ont pas un effet immédiat
parce qu'elles n'ont pas un effet absolu
mais les sanctions sont un des
différents moyens dont dispose et je ne
parle là que des sanction sur qui
permettent comment dire de limiter
l'approvisionnement en circuit en
circuit électrique en composant et puis
en arm mais quand on regarde un peu dans
le détail donc il y a quand même une
certaine efficacité croissante de ces
sanctions c'est intéressant pour nous
c'est au moment où certaines volontés
politiqu s'épuis nous notons sur le
terrain un
changement dans les chaînes
d'approvisionnement
russes pour ce qui est de la livraison
d'un certain nombre de composants
occidentaux c'est tout à fait vrai comme
comme je le rappelais la plupart des
composants qui sont utilisés dans ces
systèmes sont des composants occidentaux
ou fabriqué dans des pays alliés donc
notamment en Taïwan encore une fois au
Japon ou en Corée du Sud et non du Nord
mes excuses encore une
fois donc c'est aussi une opportunité
pour nous c'est-à-dire que on peut
travailler avec ces entreprises à tracer
les
intermédiaires et donc au lieu de voir
ça finalement comme la condition ou fin
ou un petit peu le le résultat final de
ces sanctions il faut le voir aussi
comme un moyen c'est presque pour nous
qui enquêtons sur ces sur ces sujets une
opportunité de voir que tous ces toutous
ce matériel embarque des circuits
intégrés circuits électroniques
occidentaux on peut travailler avec ces
entreprises occidentales qui sont en
règle général assez promp à nous
répondre et à collaborer avec nous enfin
pour ce qui est de la livraison des
composants français
euh je peux vous donner quelques
indications d'abord ce qu'on a documenté
comme composants français dans les
systèmes d'armement russes son soit très
peu sophistiqué soit extrêmement
sophistiqué quand on parle de très peu
sophistiqué ça peut être des câbles ou
des connecteur et très sophistiqué on
est sur du matériel qui peut équiper
qu'est-ce que je pourrais donner comme
exemple du des systèmes thermiques ou
des choses comme ça je souhaite pas
donner de nom d'entreprise puisque
l'accord que car a avec l'industrie
c'est en échange d'une collaboration de
s'assurer bien sûr que ces éléments là
resteront d'ordre privé mais ce
oui oui ce que nous observons en ce que
nous observons avec ces avec ces ces
avec ces composants français c'est que
dans certains cas c'est vrai des
composants français qui ont été
fabriqués après l'invasion de l'Ukraine
ont été livrés aux forces armé russes en
revanche quand nous avons tracé ce
matériel en l'état peu
sophistiqué ce que nous avons identifié
c'est que le fabricant français avait
conformément au régime de sanction
arrêté ses activités et ses affaires
avec un certain nombre d'entités en
Chine notamment mais que sa filiale
chinoise avait poursuit ses ses ces
affaires sur place et donc il y avait un
petit peu une il y avait un petit peu un
une sorte de de de de diarchie dans la
dans la prise de décision qui avait
occasionné quelques quelques quelques
quelques comment dire quelques livraison
à la à la Russie mais qui ont été
maintenant qui ont été toute cette
politique d'affaires a été revisitée
mais en règle générale on constate
aujourd'hui que encore une fois il n''ya
pas de livraison en direct ce que l'on
observe aujourd'hui ce sont des
livraisons par des intermédiaires que
l'on traque et quand je dis que l'on
traque ça n'est évidemment pas que
conflictament research en premier lieu
vous avez les services étatiques
occidentaux les Américains sont très en
pointe là-dessus les Européens sont très
en pointe là-dessus en France nous avons
des des personnes formidables qui
travaillent là-dessus donc tout ça pour
vous dire que selon moi ces sanctions
sont quand même relativement efficaces
simplement il faut avoir une vision je
pense peut-être réaliste de ce que
permettront ces sanctions les sont aussi
un compromis entre un régime répressif
et puis un régime coercitif y compris
pour nos entreprises et en même temps la
nécessité de poursuivre ensuite des
relations d'affaires et puis de
permettre quand même le commerce
international et donc c'est dans cette
équilibre là que que que que les
sanctions doivent un petit peu se se
trouver leur sens ce que nous
préconisons chezar c'est une coopération
beaucoup plus renforcée et facilitée
entre l'industrie les services étatiques
et les personnes y compris les
organisations comme nous qui sont
déployé sur le terrain pour que les les
informations so circuler de manière
beaucoup plus rapide entre ces
différents interlocuteurs pourquoi parce
que c'est grâce à ça que l'on peut
ensuite déterminer et identifier ses
intermédiaires et mettre fin à leurs
activités j'espère avoir répondu à votre
question monsieur le sénateur sur la
question des armes légères et des
technologies d'avenir notamment la
question des imprimantes
3D c'est une question intéressante parce
qu'effectivement dans les travaux de
prospective que nous menons nous sommes
intéressés à cette menace là
c'est-à-dire vous avez des plans libre
accès sur internet pour un pour la
production ou l'impression d'un certain
nombre de matériel dont le très fameux
fgc9 et je n'expliciterai pas ici ce que
ce que signifie cet acronyme par respect
pour les forces de
l'ordre je dirais
là-dessus que d'abord il faut aussi
comprendre que les matériels qui sont
produits par ce biaisl ne sont pas des
matériels extrêmement efficaces ce ne
sont pas des armes qui remplaceront le
matériel militaire ce sont des armes qui
sont aujourd'hui utilisées par des
criminels notamment en Europe par
exemple mais ce ne sont pas des armes
qui sontont en tout cas avec la
technologie actuelle utilisé par des
groupes
terroristes certainement pas pour faire
face à des moyens
étatiques est-ce que demain la
technologie évoluera de telle manière à
ce que l'on puisse produire de
l'armement beaucoup plus euh beaucoup
plus létal je ne sais pas et je ne suis
pas sûr je pense
que sans tout en étant tout en ayant une
âme un peu scientiste je crois quand
même
que dans ce qui est des imprimantes 3D
un peu dans ce qui est finalement de la
du monopole occidental sur la
technologie des circuits intégrés on a
tendance par parfois à être un petit peu
défétiste on a l'impression que les
autres vont pouvoir reproduire ce que
l'on ce que l'on fait on a l'impression
que l'arrivée de la 3D va finalement
très rapidement découler sur d'abord la
démocratisation et puis ensuite une de
grandes avancées technique euh ce que
nous n'observons pas ça fait finalement
quand même quelques années que nous
parlons de ce de de cette de ces
impressions 3D et il y a toujours de
vrais défis notamment pour la production
des munitions pour la résilience des
systèmes interne et que c des pièces
internes vous avez sans vouloir être
trop technique si vous imprimez chez
vous votre fgc9 que vous l'imprimez en
Europe où il est très difficile
d'obtenir un un un un petit canon donc
un un barilet euh votre votre armement
après quelques coup va probablement
faire fondre un petit peu donc les
composants internes vont fondre à cause
de la friction et de la chaleur aux
États-Unis où il est plus facile
d'obtenir ces barilet là l'arme est plus
résistante mais il arrive à un certain
moment où ce matériel-là devient
défectueux donc c'est une menace qui est
intéressante mais il faut être capable
de la caractériser c'est-à-dire ce sera
sans doute quelque chose qui sera utile
pour des groupe criminel pour de la
petite criminalité mais ce ne sera à mon
sens et
égard la technologie comme elle existe
aujourd'hui et de ce qu'on connaît de
ces récents développement ce ne sera pas
un moyen d'approvisionnement majeur pour
les groupes
terroristes voilà pour ce qui est de
l'imprimante
3D j'espère avoir répondu à la question
enfin pour ce qui est de de l'amertume
monsieur le
sénateur écoutez je je reprendrai un peu
quelques quelquesuns des éléments de
réponse que j'ai que j'ai apporté à
madame la sénatrice la la perception que
l'on a c'est que tout de même les les
sanctions fonctionne
elle fonctionne plus ou moins bien mais
on observe certains on observe certains
certains effets dans la documentation
des matériels comme je vous le disais on
observe des cycles beaucoup plus courts
il y a quand même un certain goulot
d'étranglement qui se fait sur le
matériel est-ce que cela amène à une
efficacité comme certains le voudraient
non c'est peut-être pas c'est peut-être
pas aussi efficace qu'on voudrait
certainement mais on observe une
certaine
efficacité un certain nombre d'entités
notamment en Iran ont été mises ont été
sanctionné y compris après la
documentation par car dans des drones
documentés en Ukraine et au yen de
certains de ses
composants pour ce qui est de la de la
question
de de ce que vous soullignez comme étant
un peu une forme de de de de dualisme
dans l'approche dans l'approche de notre
politique étrangère iranienne je ne suis
pas qualifié évidemment pour pour
répondre sur ce sujet mais en tout cas
je souhaite quand mêmeouigner que je
suis d'accord pour dire que les
sanctions pourraient sans doute mieux
fonctionner mais je tiens quand même à
rappeler que elles n'ont pas non plus
ell ne elles n'ont pas non plus aucun
effet
merci merci Rachid
temal merci président d'abord moi je
tiens à saluer le travail que vous menez
enfin car mène voilà deuxième chose vous
avez cité un certain nombre de pays mais
par contre il y a un pays qui est pas
revenu alors j'ai pas tout suivi
notamment y y a-t-il ou non un rôle de
la Turquie puisque c'est vous l'avez pas
cité donc peut-être que c'est soit un
oublie soit il ne le fait pas mais
c'était juste pour éclairer ma
lanterne ce qu'évoquit Roger cari j'ai
plutôt l'impression que vous êtes une
forme de thermomètre ou de baromètre
plutôt que de voilà donc c'est peut-être
ça qui qu'il faut voir et moi j'ai une
question à vous et une question qui nous
est collec à mon Président la première
c'est que concrètement c'est quoi les
deux trois grandes mesures que vous
pourriez enfin vous pourriez nous
préconiser j'entends bien votre rapport
à l'industrie votre confidentialité donc
sortez un instant de cela je parle pas
de car mais ce que vous pourvez proposer
à un parlement pour justement limiter
tenter de réduire freiner justement tous
ces tous ces trafics et en fait cette
dissémination de de la de la technologie
qui permet effectivement à soit certains
États qui sont sou normalement à des
embargos soit à des groupes et c'est là
où ça devient d'avoir justement accès à
cette technologie notamment à ces armes
destructives et puis pour nous
collectivement mais peut-être au
président avec mon groupe on avait porté
un amendement sur une proposition de
délégation de commission d'évaluation
sur la question des ventes d'armes j'ai
bien dit
d'évaluation et je crois que maintenant
il serait bien il serait temps que nous
puissions la mettre en place et désigner
nos membres parce que c'était je parle
sous le contrôle du
président qui avait porté ça avec nous
mais c'est vrai que une des avancées de
la loi de PR il y a beaucoup d'avancées
mais une des av des avancées notamment
cette commission d'évaluation de laavand
parce que nous en tout cas pour notre
groupe nous sommes favorables à ce que
l'industrie défense se développe en
France on le voit chaque jour sa
nécessité mais aussi on est favorable à
ce qui est comme pour d'autres secteurs
un rôle du Parlement pas de contrôle là
on l' évoqué mais d'évaluation et je
crois qu'il faut maintenant qu'on qu'on
avance sur ce chantier là concrètement
et qu'on la mette en place il faudrait
pas que comme sur une autre
commission on trraîne des années durant
donc il serait bon je crois que
maintenant nous
puissions désigner nos représentants
dans cette commission d'évaluation je
vous
remercie merci on a bien ça en tête mais
on attend la nomination donc on va
relancer C c'est ceux qui doivent nommer
Jean-Marc vessous oui monsieur Jarry
merci si une peut-être un petit
éclaircissement sur ces
composants électriques vous avez
identifié cette fragilité russe sur ce
risque de pénurie de ces de ces
composants ce qui dans ce contexte où il
nous semble que la symétrie est de plus
en plus importante entre la la Russie et
l'Ukraine en faveur de la Russie bien
sûr est un petit motif d'espoir les
Ukrainiens lors de notre déplacement à à
Kiev nous avait d'ailleurs interpellé
sur cette capacité à agir sur la
question des composants électrique mais
néanmoins est que un pays comme la Chine
par exemple n'est pas en capacité de
main de de produire et et de fournir ses
composants à la
Russie Jean merci Jean-Marc il avait pas
d'autres questions moi j'ai une question
je me permets du coup euh elle concerne
c'est la traçabilité des trafic don dont
vous avez par parler évidemment mais par
rapport à la à la question qui se pose
beaucoup sur la possibilité de de la du
retour d'un certain nombre d'armes qui
sont données à l'Ukraine vers un certain
nombre de nos banlieux vers un certain
nombre d'endroits un peu stratégiques
dans lequel le trafic d'armes progresse
considérablement est-ce que aujourd'hui
vous avez une traçabilité de ce point de
vue-là est-ce que vous faites des choses
est-ce qu'il y a des des des des
missions en tout cas qui vous sont qui
vous sont donné
euh j'avais noté d'autres ch chose mais
je pense que on est déjà bien merci
beaucoup merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Sénateur sur la sur la
question du rôle de la Turquie il n'est
pas omis par car qui a plusieurs fois
publié à ce sujet il n'est on n' pas
souhaité aborder aujourd'hui le rôle de
la Turquie tout simplement parce que
nous avions une approche thématique
comme nous avons travaillé dans plus de
25 pays et que nous travaillons en
Ukraine je veux dire par là j'entends ce
que je par là c'est que dans les trois
exemples que vous nous avez cité ce
matin vous avez cité un son de pays enc
une fois moi je et la question c'est si
vous n'avez pas cité la la la Turquie
c'est que dans ces trois cas d'espèces
il n'y a pas de matériel turque qui a
été identifié tout à fait voilà d'accord
nous avons observé du matériel turc ou
lié à la Turquie en Libye nous en avons
observé en Syrie mais nous n' avons pas
observé du côté des forces armées russes
en
Ukraine pour ce qui sont des deux trois
grandes des trois grandes mesures que
nous pourrions recommander un parlement
je risque de vous décevoir parce que la
lecture que nous faisons de de ce qui
est nécessaire aujourd'hui n'est pas lié
à des
mesures programmatiques c'est vraiment
lié à la question de la dissémination de
cette information c'est lié une
meilleure collaboration entre les les
ceux qui prennent des décisions au
niveau du pouvoir et les industriels le
vrai problème aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y
a très peu de de de de porosité si j'ose
dire dans l'information qui est
communiquée aux et aux autres nous avons
certains industriels qui nous disent
écoutez nous ça nous emmè beaucoup ce
que vous dites parce que ça veut dire
qu'on va devoir le déclarer ce sera des
processus extrêmement lourd on va devoir
répondre à beaucoup d'interlocuteurs on
préfère au moins avec car c'est
extrêmement rapide on on a peu à à
s'embêter de de de de
protocole une une chose aussi je pense
qui peut-être un peu revue mais c'est
plus par quel
comparaison à partir du moment où
l'Union européenne est notifiée d'une
violation éventuelle de sanction à
partir du moment où nous notifions
l'Union européenne euh de l'existence
d'un
intermédiaire la désignation de cet
intermédiaire ou la la S la sanction de
cet intermédiaire là prend beaucoup de
temps pour de bonnes raisons il y a tout
un protocole une procédure interne
notamment légal et cetera qui vise à
vérifier l'information et cetera mais il
est vrai que dans d'autres pays
notamment les États-Unis la dés tion de
de de certaines entités ou le le la
sanction de certaines entités est
beaucoup plus rapide il y a
parfois une différence de traitement de
mêmes entités entre les États-Unis par
exemple et l'Europe les États-Unis vont
sanctionner certaines entités l'Europe
est un peu plus lente c'est peut-être
quelque chose qu'il faudrait
effectivement sur lequel il faudrait
effectivement
travailler je veux aussi dire que c'est
un effort bien sûr européen nous
observons que certains pays européens et
je citerai l'exemple de la de de de des
Pays-Bas euh sont
extrêmement
coopératifs sur ce sujet c'est-à-dire
que ils partage non seulement avec nous
mais avec un certain nombre d'entités y
compris des acteurs industriels tout
àint d'information qui sont capté par
leur leur leurs services étatique qui
sont liés au tissus industriels ou au
tissus d'intermédiaire en Chine ou dans
d'autres pays ces interaction là fait
que au niveau
européen certains pays comme les
Pays-Bas sont un petit peu des exemples
pour
nous voilà est-ce que je peux vous
demander peut-être un complément de en
tout cas des précisions concernant le ce
que vous avez affirmé en premier lieu
concernant la la les lourdeurs
administratives qui sont subies par les
entreprises et qui les amènent à à
considérer qu'elles ont ENF qu' est plus
simple pour elle de traiter avec car
est-ce que vous pouvez préciser parce
que j'ai pas tout à fait alors lorsque
nous nous lorsque car prend un tâche
avec une entreprise évidemment
l'entreprise nous communique un peu les
informations qu'elle souhaite elle ne
fait pas l'objet d'une enquête à propre
command dit et cetera et en règle
générale elle elle collabore avec nous
afin que nous puissions ensuite rendre
compte aux autorités en expliquant que
tout a déjà été
clarifié ce que certaines de entreprises
ont bien voulu nous faire parvenir ou
bien voulu nous expliquer c'est que bah
parfois lorsque
elles sont soupsonné ou où elles sont
leur production a été détournée au
profit des forces armées russes et
cetera et qu'elles échangent avec les
services de l'État ou avec des service
d'enquête la communication est beaucoup
plus longue c'est beaucoup plus lourd
voilà il y a vraiment c'est c'est
peut-être la nature même des choses je
dis
je c'est en tout cas un retour que l'on
a sur
euh sur la question aussi de des mesures
ce qu'il faut voir c'est que l'assiette
des
sanctions est assez modulable en l'État
c'est-à-dire que les seules sanctions si
je dire fourout c'est-à-dire qui serait
qui
[Musique]
qui qui comment dire qui désignerait ou
qui qui qui qui qui santionnerait toute
entité liée à un certain sujet sont liés
à la question des armes de destruction
massive à partir du moment où vous avez
un élément qui est lié soit la une arme
de destruction massive soit ce qui
permet l'emport le transport ou le ou le
portage de cette arme de destruction
massive vous tombez sous le con sous le
coup sous le coup de sanction donc on
pourrait arguer du fait que certains
missiles russes notamment le le KH 101
dispose d'une version similaire le kh102
dont la seule différence c'est d'avoir
une ogive nucléaire et de dire bah à
partir de ce ce moment-là tout ce qui se
retrouve dans le cash 100 et cetera les
intermétiires et autres tombe sous le
coup de sanction un petit peu Fourtout
ça ça n'existe pas pour pour ce qui est
de de tous les composants possibles tout
simplement parce que ben ça ça ça
mettrait une pression énorme sur les
opérateurs industriels encore une fois
je je ne dis pas que je ne dis pas que
c'est c'est c'est c'est bienou mal mais
je dis simplement qu'il y a malgré tout
un équilibre à avoir entre la capacité
de ces opérateurs de continuer à
commercialiser et les sanctions on ne
peut pas selon moi interdire le commerce
intern national à ses acteurs pour ce
qui est en notamment des intermédiaires
en Chine le plus important pour nous
c'est d'être capable de travailler avec
ces acteurs industriels pour très en
amont être capable d'identifier ces
intermédiaires ce qui selon moi manque
c'est d'une coopération très renforcée
ou des services de l'État ou des
services privés en coopération avec les
services de l'État serait capable de
dire aux entreprises attention sur ces
nouveaux clients que vous pouvez avoir
là il y a des points d'interrogation il
y a pas de list il y a pas de liste en
tout cas qui sont communiqué largement
aux entreprises nous nous travaillons
avec ell nous nous avons étit certaines
listes que nous communiquons à l'Union
européenne mais après effectivement
c'est et puis encore une fois comme
parfois certaines certaines entités
mettent du temps à être sanctionné
évidemment vous pouvez avoir entre-temps
d'éventuelles d'éventuelles affaires qui
se
réalisent voilà j'espère que ça a
répondu partiellement à votre
question pour ce qui est de la la
question de la fragilité
des chaînes d'approvisionnement
russes et notamment des capacités
chinoises je je tiens à souligner une
chose c'est que ce que nous observons
c'est que la Chine est très importante
pour les réseaux de
distribution mais n'est pas
particulièrement importante pour ce qui
est de la fabrication des composants et
du matériel certaines pièces vont
pouvoir être fabriquées en Chine c'est
le cas par exemple de de moteur de
certains circuits intégrés mais c'est
limité c'est en général spécifique
peut-être parfois du matériel de pointe
mais très limité c'est-à-dire limité
dans dans comment dire ça n'est pas ça
n'est pas une large gamme de matériel
que vous pourrez que pour pour système
d'armes avancé que vous pourrez
récupérer en Chine c'est lié un petit
peu à ce monopole bien sûr
occidental est-ce que les capacités de
production de la Chine s'amélioreront à
l'avenir peut-être je pense que les
annonces chinoises notamment sur les
puces que les nouvelles puces qu'il
qu'il qu'ils embarquent dans leur
téléphone vont peut-être en ce sens cela
dit il y a aussi beaucoup de
communication politique derrière tout ça
euh cette volonté d'affirmer son
indépendance et sa prééminence sur ces
sur ces sujets-là ce que l'on observe
aujourd'hui nous concrètement c'est que
sur les systèmes critiques des des sur
les sur les composants critiques des
systèmes d'armes avancés en Russie et
documentés en Ukraine il n'y a pas de
remplacement des des des matériels
occidentaux à large
échelle enfin pour ce qui est de
monsieur le Président de la traçabilité
de ce trafic là et des risques peut
peser d'éventuels détournement des
stocks attribué à
l'Ukraine effectivement c'est une c'est
un défi
majeur je ferai un parallèle avec ce
qu'on a pu observer sur un autre théâtre
c'est en Libye pour répondre à votre
question je dirais que quand un conflit
fait rage les armes sont en général
utilisées ù elles sont mises de côté
dans des stocks pour remplacer celles
qui viendrai devenir défectueus à être
perdu et
cetera et elles ne font pas
nécessairement l'objet de trafic il y a
pas vraiment de d'intérêt pour les
personnels combattants de se défaire de
leur stock en revanche lorsqu'un conflit
se gèle ou lorsqu'un conflit même ce ce
se résorbe vous avez parfois un effet
assez délétaire sur les stocks qui ont
été tétaquis l'exemple sur la Libye est
le suivant nous avons observé après la
bataille pour Tripoli en 2020 lorsque
les forces du du maréchal aftar à l'est
de la Libye ont tenté de prendre la
capitale et qu'elles ont qu'elles ont
failli et donc qu'elles ont procédé à
une retraite elles ont laissé derrière
elles un grand nombre de matériel un
grand grand volume d'armes et de
munitions qui ont été acquises par des
milices de Tripoli et d'autres le
conflit sétant un peu à peu gelé après
ces événements là les lignes de front
s'étaient un peu peu à peu
fixé beaucoup d'opérateurs beaucoup de
miliciens et cetera se sont dit mais
finalement c'est stock d'armes là n'ont
plus vraiment d'intérêt militaire ou
opérationnel pour nous ce sont des piles
de cache qui
dorment et ces stocks ont commencer à
être écoulé notre crainte pour nous
c'est que lorsque le conflit se gèlera
ou lorsque le conflit se résorbera et
cetera que la tension politique que le
se se se diminuera sur cette région
effectivement les risques de
détournements de ces matériels
grandiront est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on
observe des détournements majeurs non
en tout cas car n'en observe pas
euh j'attire quand même votre attention
sur le fait qu'on a certainement un
billet là-dessus c'est qu'on travaille
avec les autorités ukrainiennes euh et
qu'il est tout à fait possible que des
services étatiques que ce soit en Europe
ou ailleurs a pris connaissance de de
détournement auquel nous nous n'avons
pas
accès j'entends bien votre réponse mais
ma question euh aussi plus précisément
concerernit en C cas les les saisies
d'armes qui sont faites en France par
par les autorités est-ce qu'elles sont s
est-ce que vous les tracez est-ce que
vous êtes en capacité aujourd'hui de le
faire est-ce que vous les services vous
consultent euh pour voir un petit peu si
ce sont des armes qui friennent de liby
duuc ou je ne sais où est-ce que quelque
c'est quelque chose que vous
faites merci pour votre question non
nous n'avons pas de de de coopération
particulière avec avec les services de
sécurité est-ce que ça vous semblerait
nécessaire ou fa ouou ou
souhaitable il serait souhaitable
évidemment que cela soit fait peut-être
déjà en interne qui est un travail de
traçage qui soit fait je ne suis pas au
fait d'unité dédié à la question du
traçage ce serait selon moi
utile d'abord pour regarder un petit peu
les corrélations existantes pour savoir
effectivement si certains de ces
armements ne partagent pas des origines
communes avec de l'armement qui aurit
été détourné
ailleurs je ne sais pas aujourd'hui si
cela est souhaitable ou possible avec
avec ces avec ces forces
merci beaucoup je crois qu'il y avait
une derni vous aviez terminé ou je ne
sais pas je vous ai compris alors il a
une dernière question d'Olivier
sigoletti oui merci monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur Jarry mais vous
venez de répondre en partie à ma
question qui portait sur les les stocks
libiens qui ne constitue plus
aujourd'hui une source
d'approvisionnement pour les groupes
armé terroristes qui interviennent en
Afrique de l'Ouest ce qui paraît normal
puisque ces stocks ont été plié dès 2011
et et sur cette dernière décennie est-ce
que sur cette période vous avez pu
identifier à la fois la la nature et
l'origine de ces armements est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus sur
ces sur ces
éléments merci monsieur le sénateur
alors c'est une question assez sensible
parce que elle nécessiterait pour nous
de désigner ou pointer du doigt certains
pays ce que nous ne pouvons pas faire
publiquement bien
sûr nous avons effectivement observé
donc euh à l'issue si j'ose dire non pas
nécessairement de l'épuisement
mais plutôt à l'Ô de l'évolution que N
que Don dont j'ai parlé dans cette
présentation c'est-à-dire du fait que
nous observons une part croissante de
matériel qui a été introduit en Libye
après 2011 qui a été fabriqué après 2011
nous avons effectivement retracer
l'origine de ces armes et identifier
certains
pays comme étant les
convoyeurs de ce
matériel c'est une question sensible
parce que car a communi ces
informations à ces pays évidemment aux
autorités libyennes et aux autorités des
pays dans lesquels nous avons documenté
ces
matériels je suis en mesure de vous dire
qu'effectivement un certain nombre de
ces armes
euh comment dire qu'un certain nombre de
ces armes avaient été introduit y
compris assez récemment
2018-29 que un certains effort avaient
été fait pour effacer les marquages mais
que ça n'est jamais quelque chose de de
de de très efficace euh et que
semble-t-il ces flux d'armement se sont
taris
depuis nous observons moins aujourd'hui
d'armement extrêmement récent
c'est-à-dire nous n'observons pas
d'armement qui a été produit en 2022
2023 nous avons observé de l'armement
euh qui était produit en 2020 qui était
constitué de fusil d'assaut euh de de de
variantes de de d'Aka si j'ose
dire ces fusils d'assaut avaient été
produits dans un certain nombre de pays
en Chine en Europe de l'Est et cetera
sans que les autorités de ces pays-là ne
soient coupablebl en quoi que ce soit du
détournement de de C de ces armes et de
ces munitions dans le en Libye nous
avons même certains cas très
intéressants d'armement de munition en
l'état produites en Europe
euh envoyé en Amérique du Nord arrivé
ensuite
au
Sahel documenté alors qu'elle provenait
de Libye et en réalité on s on avait
tout de suite imaginé chez car toute une
toute une histoire derrière tout ça et
puis on s'est rendu compte que c'était
quelque chose qui avait été perdu par
les forces de des forces régional non
pas libyenne puis ensuite trafiqué vers
la Libye c'est une petite anecdote mais
il faut voir que la Libye est parfois
aussi les les milices libiennes sont
parfois aussi clientes de ce trafic
d'armes
euh et donc vous avez parfois de
l'armement qui provient des stocks
nationaux du Sahel par exemple qui perdu
lors d'attaque de page ou de
détournement se retrouent en Libye et
ensuite peuvent redescendre et donc je
je tenais juste à à souligner cela pour
dire qu'il y a une certaine complexité
de ces flux et que parfois on observe du
matériel qui est de fabrication très
récente mais on prend notre temps avant
d'affirmer que le pays fabricant ou que
ou que le ou que les pays intermédiaires
sont nécessairement coupables d'une
violation des sanctions
voilà vous nous confirmez monsieur jar
que c'était un stock le stock libien
était un stock vivant c'était pas un
stock
initial de 2011 et réénér c'est un stock
qui a été régénéré oui tout à fait c'est
un stock régénéré et c'est quelque chose
encore une fois qu'on a
observé de manière croissante dans les
saisies qui ont été faites par les par
les forces au Niger au Mali au Burkina y
compris au Nigeria depuis 2 début 2021
notamment d'ailleurs en conséquence de
la bataille de 2020 pour Tripoli et de
la dynamique que j'ai décrite où le
conflit se gant s'immobilisant bien il y
avait un intérêt matériel évident à
écouler ce surplus de
stock merci Monsieur Jarry
euh moi je vous remercie très
sincèrement pour cette audition j'espère
qu'elle a plu aux collègues parce que je
pensais depuis quelques temps maintenant
qu'il était important qu'on vous entende
et je pense qu'on le refera de manière
assez régulière il y a plusieurs leçons
je pense qu'il faut qu'on retienne de
tout cela finalement c'est que d'abord
et vous l'avez affirmé en premier que
les Russes depuis maintenant
2014 anticipe les conflits stock du
matériel et prévoit des sanctions pour
pouvoir passer à travers les sanctions
et continuer à fabriquer du matériel ce
qui quand même doit nous donner à
réfléchir je pense
collectivement sur la capacité à
anticiper à prèsvoir un certain nombre
d'événements et je pense que
notre nos récents débats ici
sous la présidence du président Cambon
au moment de la loi de programmation
militaire démontre que nous n'avions pas
complètement tort quand nous disions
qu'il fallait aussi savoir prévoir le
pire malheureusement et les Russes ont
su le faire l' la seconde leçon je
dirais c'est que finalement on se rend
compte d'après ce que vous dites que
l'Occident reste technologiquement
supérieur à un certain nombre de pays
qui aujourd'hui pourtant sont des
concurrents sur le plan militaire et et
je j'ai la conviction que cette
supériorité on la conserve parce que
c'est un un un un des domaines peut-être
le seul domaine d'ailleurs dans lequel
nous n'avons pas délocalisé massivement
notre industrie vers des pays tiers
parce que c'est évidemment une question
de souveraineté et là aussi si je puis
me permettre ça donne à réfléchir un
certain nombre de points qui aujourd'hui
nous pose un certain nombre de problèmes
aux uns et aux autres et contre lesquels
nous avons bien du mal de lutter
collectivement et je vous remercie donc
pour ces affirmations qui me semble très
importante un autre point c'est celui
que aujourd'hui la traçabilité des armes
que vous êtes en capacité de de mettre
en œuvre sur les différentes thes
d'opération et notamment celui de
l'Ukraine démontre très clairement que
l'Iran est un fournisseur de
matériel auprès de la Russie pour lui
permettre en tout cas de continuer cette
guerre contrairement à ce qui est
affirmé régulièrement en tout cas par
les par l'armée par le pouvoir russe et
c'est évidemment un élément qui permet
aujourd'hui de l'affirmer publiquement
puisque notre audition est captée et
d'affirmer publiquement que cette aide à
l'Ukraine qui est qui n'est pas une une
a aide que on pourrait imaginer mais une
aide qui est renseignée aujourd'hui très
concrètement est une aide à la Russie
importante et et puis le dernier point
c'est celui de l'importance des
sanctions on l'a mesuré lorsque nous
sommes allés en Ukraine il y a 3
semaines un mois avec Jean-Marc musfor
Rena legle Olivier sigolotti et et
et deux administrateurs que sont Marc
Chor et et et Pascal Jean-Pascal piss
les Ukrainiens nous ont expliqué que
l'année 2025 pourrait être une année
difficile pour les Russes parce que euh
les stocks de matériels ou en tout cas
de de fourniture de matériel pour
pouvoir constituer des armes arrivaient
dans des dans une période critique et
donc l'importance de cette fourn de de
ces sanctions est importante parce qu'on
a on a tendance parfois à penser que les
sanctions ne ne créant pas en tout cas
les effets escomptés initialement il
pe-être pas utile de continuer à les
mettre en œuvre et vous avez démontrer
le contraire exactement et donc c'est
très important et c'est important aussi
parce que euh lorsquonon a use parfois
ou qu'on oppose à l'Occident
l'incapacité à fournir des armes de très
grande valeur ou en tout cas de de cût
de fabrication très important ça peut
être important intéressant aussi de je
dire de couper les
circuits afin de ne pas permettre au
russes de pouvoir fabriquer des
matériels qui nous obligeront à fournir
des matériels beaucoup plus chers pour
pouvoir s'y opposer donc merci vraiment
très sincèrement pour votre exposé qui
était très intéressant
euh on n pas F enfin on n'est pas allé
au fond du du problème et des des sujets
qu'on avait traité des les années
précédentes avec les vraiment des des
réseaux des traçabilités mais ça c'est
quelque chose peut-être qu'on pourra
faire si ça intéresse les collègues dans
quelques temps mais merci beaucoup pour
cette audition cétait très intéressant
et je vous souhaite évidemment de
continuer à à travailler efficacement au
service des des organisations qui vous
demande de le faire un grand merci
monsieur le Président merci à vous
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
bien sûr car reste à votre entière
disposition si vous souhaitiez avoir de
plus en plus informations sur certains
des des sujets que nous avons abordé ou
sur d'autres théâtres sur lesqueles nous
opérons Merci à
VOUS
euh